Vaise tumhe yaad hai aaj kya hai?
Aaj ka din kaise bol sakta hun?
Badkismati se aaj ka din tumse meri shaadi ho gayi thi.
Tum bhi na, mazak karna kab chhodoge?
Chalo main office ke lie late ho raha hun.
Are saab, kaisi rahi hai Goa ki trip?
Kaun gaya Goa?
Pichhle hafte to aap gaye the?
Paagal hai kya? Kuch bhi boley jaa rahaa hai.
Are, aa gaya aap?
Pata nahin kaart ko kya ho gaya?
Kah raha hai pichhle haf‌te main Goa gaya tha.
Main kaise cheezein bhool sakta hun?
Lekin gaye to the aap.
Tum bhi paagal ho gaye ho kya?
Are yaar, bata nahin sab paagal ho gaya hai?
Kah rahe hain pichhle hafṭe Goa gaya tha?
Tu pichhle hafṭe goā gayā thā tu thā?
Tu bhi pagal ho gaya hai kya
Ye dekh photos teri gua ki
Tumne mere jeene ke azaadi cheen rakhi thi
Hamne thoda sa paisa kya maang diya tha
Tumne to mujhe apna gulaam samajh liya
Ghalat to mere saath bhi bahut kuchh hua hai
Isliye ham sabne milke tumhare dimaag se khelne ka plan banaya.
Aur tum haar gaye
To hame badla udena pada